the opening scene shows us a frantic man
in a house that is trashed he's watering
a tree in his backyard that's almost
completely dead except for a single
Branch with a few green leaves hanging
on for dear life as the camera zooms
into his face the man turns around and
we see his mouth has been tapped if he
speaks one more sentence he will die but
how did he end up in this situation well
watch on to find out the scene shifts
back a few weeks ago Jack McCall is a
literary agent whose job is to find
talented writers and sell their books to
Publications Jack is an amazing
businessman and an even more talented
talker he is known among his colleagues
for being able to talk anyone into doing
anything Jack also has a beautiful wife
Caroline and a one-year-old son who he
loves dearly but he often neglects his
family for work Caroline is used to
taking care of her baby on her own and
is tired of her husband's nonchalance
towards his family duties one morning in
his office Jack finds out that a famous
spiritual Guru Dr sinya is in the city a
book written by him would definitely be
a super hit and bring in a lot of money
which Peaks Jack's interest he pitches
the idea to his team who are skeptical
if a spiritual leader will sign a deal
with them but Jack reminds them how
amazing his skills of persuasion are the
very next day he books a meditation
session with Dr sinja in hopes of
meeting him however when it comes to the
actual meditation he is unserious and
distracted just when the session is
about to end Jack pretends to be
overwhelmed and is taken aside by Dr
sinja himself as they chat Jack cleverly
tells him that he wishes to spread the
doctor's work to the world in the form
of a book Dr singer realizes Jack's
intentions and walks into his backyard
uninterested in his offer the backyard
has a sacred Bodhi Tree which gives Jack
a splinter when he tries to touch it the
men dismissed the tiny wound and
continue talking about Jack's offer
after he explains how much he respects
Dr sinja and his teachings the guru
finally agrees to work with him a
thrilled Jack cancels his schedule for
the rest of the day to visit his mother
and tell her about his recent success
she lives in Illinois age home and has
dementia which causes her to frequently
misname her son jack had never had a
good relationship with his late father
Raymond hence when his mother calls him
by his father's name he is visibly upset
the day gets even worse for him in the
evening when he and Caroline get into an
argument Caroline wants to move into a
family-friendly neighborhood so their
son can grow up in a better environment
but Jack doesn't want to leave The
Bachelor Pad they live in he instead
suggests they paint the studio room to
turn it into a kid's Nursery in the
middle of the argument the couple feels
the ground shaking within seconds the
entire house starts moving and a Bodhi
Tree Grows out of nowhere in the
backyard Jack looks at the Magnificent
tree dumbfounded and realizes that it
looks identical to the tree that gave
him a splinter it even has the red mark
that the original tree had he eventually
comes to the conclusion that Dr sinja
sent it to him as a gift the following
morning Jack is thrilled to receive Dr
Singh's book that he thinks will make
him Millions however his plan is in vain
when he finds out the book is only five
pages long assuming that Dr sinja
playing a joke on him Jack goes to his
ashram only to find out that the
spiritual leader wants to keep the book
short he argues that this is a breach of
contract but Dr Cinder remains adamant
in his decision as they chat Jack brings
up the tree in his backyard which Peaks
Dr Singh's interest they go to his house
to check it and see that a branch has no
leaves while the rest of the tree is
green after inspecting it for a while Dr
sinja comes to a shocking Revelation
Jack's life is now tied to the tree
every word he speaks will cause a leaf
to shed which means when there are no
more leaves left his life will end as
well checks out Jack freaks out and
tries to ax the tree down but ends up
hurting only himself this is when it is
revealed that if the tree is harmed Jack
will suffer with it he has no way to
save himself other than to stop speaking
entirely Dr sinja promises to help him
after Consulting his colleagues in
Bolivia but even that will take three
days the next morning Jack wakes up from
a nightmare and tries to leave a note
for his wife it doesn't take him long to
find out that every word he writes will
also make a leaf fall in fact fact if he
tries to communicate with anyone in any
way the tree will reciprocate in the
following scene he hopelessly goes to
work and comes across several hurdles in
the way because of his new disability
the Barista gives him wrong orders of
coffee and he causes an accident trying
to save a blind man however the day only
gets worse for him at work when he is
introduced to an important investor who
he cannot talk to as he tries to get
through the conversation two squirrels
start climbing up the tree at home as a
result Jack feels ticklish and starts
laughing making a fool out of himself
later that day he brings his assistant
Aaron to a meeting hoping that he can
communicate with the investors in the
middle of it Jack sweats profusely
because of the tree being watered at
home the investors try to ignore the
elephant in the room but the meeting
ends in a disaster because of Aaron's
lack of communication skills after a
long day when Jack finally reaches home
Caroline tries to talk to him about
their relationship she takes his silence
as anger causing a bigger argument and
walking out with the baby within only a
day of living with the curse Jack has
lost his biggest investors and his
family is hanging by a thread the
reality of it all hits him like a storm
making him feel helpless he tries
calling Dr sinja in Bolivia for an
update and wastes several leaves but
doesn't get an answer the next day
Caroline makes a final attempt to
salvage their marriage by calling jack
to a hotel room for a steamy night he
sees her waiting for him in lingerie and
excitedly enters the room but things
start going downhill soon when Caroline
asks him if he loves her all Jack can
say is the word yes which pushes
Caroline to leave him for good right
after Jack has to go to yet another
meeting with the investors who he blew
yesterday he blew this is the final
chance he has to impress them and
apologize for the previously failed
meeting although nervous Jack does his
best to fit in but luck just doesn't
seem to be working on his side at home
The Gardener sprays pesticides on the
Bodhi Tree this causes Jack to cough
uncontrollably nonetheless his boss
tries to keep the meeting going before
Jack gets high on the chemical and stuff
Buffs her nose with a stick this sex is
the last straw for the investors who no
longer want to associate with someone so
childish after the meeting Jack's boss
fires him making sure he is blacklisted
from the industry at the end of the day
he frustratedly goes home and calls his
assistant Aaron over using a picture he
tries explaining the situation to the
poor Aaron who finally gets it after
several hours when he refuses to believe
the curse exists Jack has to waste more
words to prove himself after that he
keeps Aaron in charge of observing the
tree and goes around the city doing
random acts of kindness he feeds the
poor donates to a church and helps a cat
stuck in a tree all well on the phone
with Aaron but nothing breaks the curse
eventually Aaron has to go back to the
office and Jack is left alone again he
helplessly sits in front of the tree and
meditates when relaxed Jack imagines his
childhood he remembers how he had a
happy family until his father left his
mother and abandoned him even years
later he has not been able to forgive
his father for his deeds and it has
always bothered him suddenly Jack wakes
up from from the relaxed State and finds
out Dr sinja is back in town with eyes
full of hope he rushes to meet the guru
only to be told that nothing can be done
about the situation Dr sinja has asked
every enlightened Guru he knows but no
one has an answer at this point all he
can say is that Jack has to make peace
with something within himself to break
the curse losing all will to live Jack
returns homined resorts to drinking
Aaron comes to his rescue and tries
helping him but Jack has decided to end
his life by singing to a song the tree
loses most of its leaves before Aaron
knocks Jack out and sticks duct tape
over his mouth as the camera pans
towards the tree we see that only one
branch of leaves are left the next
morning Jack wakes up knowing that it is
his last day on Earth he listens to his
heart and knows exactly what he wants to
do with the last few words he has left
to speak first he goes to Caroline and
tells her he loves her he then helps a
struggling writer who he has been
ignoring for months by buying his work
for ten thousand dollars next he goes
for a walk on the beach and observes
people living their lives and all old
couple talking about their love life
reminds him of his childhood finally
when it starts to get dark he goes to
his mother she mistakes him for his
father again but this time Jack goes
along with it he listens as she happily
reveals how successful her son is and
how proud she is of him however there is
one thing she doesn't like about Jack he
has too much hatred in his heart and he
refuses to let go of it she knows that
he is suffering because of the grudge he
holds against his father and believes it
is time for him to let it go although
Jack cannot speak he is still left
speechless he finally understands that
no matter the amount of success he
achieves he will never be happy until he
forgives his father determined to do the
right thing Jack tells his mother that
he loves her leaving only the last three
leaves on the tree in the following
scene Jack goes to his father's grave
and in a moment of epiphany tells him
that he forgives him with his last words
spent there are no leaves left on the
tree consequently a sharp pain hits his
chest and he falls to the ground a few
seconds later his phone starts ringing
and he picks it up with all his
remaining strength on the other end
Aaron tells Jack he won't believe what
just happened the tree is magically
green again and the curse is broken the
scene changes to a few months later Dr
sinja calls Jack to his ashram to
congratulate him on writing a book it is
called a thousand words and is about
Jack's story and his relationship with
his father after the curse was broken he
is turned into a different person he is
now a family man who is genuinely happy
with his life in the meantime Aaron has
taken Jack's Place in the office and is
as arrogant as his boss was he is soon
about to learn his own lesson which he
will get from the Bodhi Tree that
magically appears in his office
somewhere else Jack surprises Caroline
by getting her the house she really
wanted in an area where their child can
have a good life he has planted a boaty
tree in the yard to remember the lessons
he has learned the movie ends as the
couple plays with their child in their
new house subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching